I must have at one point said something
to the extent of yeah they're like are
you 18 I must have been like yeah sure
do you know how many actors tell lies to
get apart a lot more than you'd probably
think let's get into it number one can
you imagine anyone else as Max yeah well
that was almost a reality the producers
of the show were looking for a girl who
could skateboard and Sadie had never set
foot on a board before they asked me oh
do you have any rollerblading experience
I was like uh sure I do which was
technically not a lie because I have
rollerbladed before she hadn't
rollerbladed in well over a year and was
definitely not confident in her ability
to do so after landing the role she
ended up learning how to skateboard in a
month number two she really pulled one
over on us not only did Phoebe dinosaur
lie and say she was a skilled horseback
rider during her audition for Bridgerton
but she's also terrified of horses in
the audition when they asked me have you
ridden a horse before I was like yeah
I'm amazing I've ridden so many horses
I'd be perfect for this role after she
was cast she started horseback riding
lessons right away with her co-star
reggae Jean page she actually loved
horseback riding by the end of it and
was eager to get back on a horse and
show off her Newfound skills number
three did you know that most of the
wakanda Forever cast had to learn how to
swim there was no way tainoch Huerta was
going to turn down the role of nemour
even if one of his biggest Feats was
being able to breathe underwater when
director Ryan coogler asked him about
his swimming abilities technically he
didn't lie I never lie I never drowned
before so that's not a lie though he
definitely had not drowning under his
belt he needed some serious swimming
lessons to be comfortable enough in the
water to portray the role number four
who needs a driver's license anyway Paul
meskel apparently for him his role of
Connell in normal people yeah you got
that right Paul mascal didn't have a
driver's license during the time of his
audition for the show my agent was like
we are not losing this job over you not
being able to drive so I'll tell
production that you can and in the
meantime you go off and rattle through
as many lessons as you can his driving
was a crucial part of the story so we
assume he passed his driver's test with
flying colors number five what's a
little FIB about your age nowadays
apparently for Rebel Wilson her little
FIB turned into some major drama when
auditioning for Pitch Perfect Rebel
Wilson told the casting directors that
she was 29 when she was in fact in her
mid-30s this truly isn't a big deal but
at the time everyone thought it was an
Australian tabloid published a feature
exposing Rebels FIB about her age which
resulted in her losing multiple movie
deals she ended up suing the Tabloid and
won over 3 million dollars number six
his exaggerated horseback riding
abilities ended up coming to light in an
unfortunate way Eddie Redmayne is an
extremely talented actor with tons of
awards and nominations in his back
pocket but the guy cannot ride a horse
to save his life they called action and
I basically went ferociously down at 100
miles an hour he almost severely injured
himself his castmates and half the crew
in an embarrassing call out Tom Hooper
came out from behind Helen Mirren with a
loud speaker and screamed you're an
effing liar Redmayne number seven what
would That 70s Show have been without
Jackie when Mila Kunis auditioned for
the show she told the casting directors
that she was turning 18. when in fact
she was only 14 and yes Ashton Kutcher
did feel a little weird having to do
kissing scenes with her because of the
age difference but at some point she did
turn 18. legally I was 14 but I told
them I was a little bit older I told
them I was gonna be 18 which is not
technically a lie because at one point I
was gonna be 18. number eight who knew
going to Oxford was important to the
casting directors of Harry Potter we
couldn't imagine anyone else playing
Cedric Diggory in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire but if Robert Pattinson
didn't lie about his education he might
not have been cast I'd been unemployed
for ages and when I came to Los Angeles
and the casting directors would ask what
I'd been doing for the past few years
I'd say oh I was at Rada the Royal
Academy of dramatic art if you've got an
English accent you can get away with it
I'd say I went to Oxford too I did it
for years number nine British why not
when Chloe Grace Moretz was trying to
land the role of Isabel in the movie
Hugo she pretended to be British in
front of the director he flew ASA and I
out to New York to audition in front of
him and I spoke in a British accent the
whole time I stayed in character with
Marty until the end when I thanked him
and walked out he said said hold on did
I hear an American accent I said maybe
and he replied you tricked me number 10.
Chris Hemsworth is constantly lying
about his height this is one of the few
times where someone lies about being
shorter than they actually are the guy
stands at an insane six foot three there
are certainly things I've wanted to go
up for which I've been totally wrong for
physically and I normally lie about my
height and say I'm shorter but it can go
two ways the brief for the audition for
Thor said must be over six foot one
which I'd never seen before number 11.
taking a few pages from his brother's
Playbook when Liam Hemsworth was
auditioning for the last song one of the
necessary qualifications was that he
know how to play volleyball how hard
could it be he thought apparently
extremely difficult so difficult in fact
that he asked for a body double I turned
up for the first day of volleyball
practice and I was honestly really
scared to shoot the volleyball part
because it takes a lot of skill skills
to play that game and I didn't have them
at all I said to Julianne I think we're
going to need a double number 12. we've
got another horse related incident here
when trying to land her role in to the
wonder she didn't lie about being able
to ride horses but just the fact that
she liked them while this may not seem
like a big deal Rachel is actually very
allergic to horses I said I love horses
but I'm so terrified and allergic her
eyes ended up swelling up so bad that it
made it hard for her to see number 13.
we don't know what it is about horses
that make people wanna lie apparently at
the end of her audition for Brokeback
Mountain the director asked her if she
could ride a horse Anne Hathaway's
parents taught her that whenever someone
asks her if she could do something just
say yes because she can learn in two
weeks so I'd never been on a horse and I
replied oh yeah I'm a really good Rider
so I knew I had to learn to ride and I
got really really really good good
number 14 who wouldn't lie to get on
Breaking Bad when Laura Frazier got word
that Breaking Bad was casting for the
character Lydia she was willing to do
whatever it took to land the role which
included lying about her ability to
speak German the role required fluency
but Laura had never spoken the language
before she ended up spending hours
learning German which was vital to the
show's final season it was corporate
speak German and it was a nightmare it
took me days to learn a little paragraph
now I bore my family with it it's my
party trick number 15 she just added a
few extra years to her age no big deal
when trying to snag the role of Diane
Farrow in Love Potion Number Nine Sandra
Bullock had to tell a little FIB for the
casting directors to be convinced she
was right for it after a while you have
no idea how old you are because you've
lied so many times I always said I would
never lie but one time when I didn't it
worked against me so I figure you just
keep them guessing it's not an easy
thing to be an actor especially when you
have to remember all the necessary lies
you've told to land a role who's your
favorite actor from this list let us
know in the comments
[Music]